en este vídeo hablaremos sobre la
apoptosis hice una investigación
etimológica y encontré que la palabra
apoptosis proviene del griego appo que
significa lejos y ptosis que significa
que cae entonces tiene que ver con una
caída y bueno la apoptosis es una forma
de muerte celular programada y es muy
similar a la caída de las hojas de un
árbol es decir que es algo que tiene que
pasar así que las células simplemente
mueren de forma programada cuando tienen
que hacerlo y no es algo que ocurra
aleatoriamente esto es algo que las
células tienen que pasar para un
propósito en particular esa es una buena
forma de explicarlo yo creo que por eso
las primeras personas que la estudiaron
le pusieron así porque de esa manera nos
dan a entender que se refiere a una
forma de muerte celular y que es muy
normal de hecho es una parte saludable
en el desarrollo de un organismo es un
mantenimiento para nuestro cuerpo y es
una forma de prevenir
afecciones virales o incluso cáncer así
que es algo muy normal y saludable que
nuestros cuerpos se están realizando e
incluso en este momento si en este
momento y tal vez me digan ok pero
entonces cuáles son las formas en las
que puede morir una célula bueno miren
aquí tenemos una célula saludable pero
después aquí parece que explotó qué
significa esto
bueno aquí se muestran las dos
categorías más importantes por las que
pueden morir una célula y la forma más
simple de identificarlas es que una es
desordenada y la otra es ordenada pero
más formalmente la célula que parece que
explotó está sufriendo una necrosis la
necrosis es una forma de muerte celular
en la que la célula básicamente se
hincha y luego explota liberando su
contenido y eso no es muy bueno porque
puede dañar a otras células cercanas
puede atraer células del sistema
inmunológico y eso a su vez provocará
inflamación pero en el otro caso tenemos
la forma ordenada
o mejor conocida como apoptosis y aquí
podemos ver que la célula se está
encogiendo su adn y su núcleo se están
rompiendo aquí tenemos pequeños
fragmentos de cromosomas que se han
separado aunque en la realidad son más
pequeños de lo que hemos dibujado aquí
pero entonces todos los componentes de
la célula empezarán a romperse en
pequeños fragmentos que de alguna manera
quedarán envueltos en una membrana y
después las células del sistema
inmunológico cuyo trabajo es básicamente
comerse los restos celulares vendrán y
se comerán esos fragmentos y será como
si nada hubiera pasado o si quieren
verlo de otra forma esta es una gran
diferencia entre dejar nuestra basura
dentro de una bolsa de basura y aventar
la por la ventana de nuestra casa pero
en este caso llevado a otro nivel porque
por ejemplo si dejamos nuestra basura en
bolsas de basura que sería como cuando
ocurre el apoptosis a veces podemos
reutilizar algo de esa basura y eso
es muy interesante porque de la misma
forma otras células pueden usar esos
componentes para otros propósitos así
que en este caso las otras células no
sufren un daño si hay cosas
desagradables flotando por ahí ahora
cuáles serán las circunstancias bajo las
que puede ocurrir la apoptosis qué tan
común es la apoptosis y qué tan común es
la necrosis bueno generalmente la
necrosis es algo que nuestro cuerpo no
quiere que pase porque ocurre cuando una
célula es expuesta a una sustancia
química tóxica o cuando una célula es
lesionada físicamente estas son las
circunstancias en las que podríamos
decir que una célula prácticamente
recibe un insulto que le provoca la
muerte de una forma descontrolada
mientras que la apoptosis es algo que
ocurre continuamente desde que un ser
humano o cualquier vertebrado es un
embrión y que sigue ocurriendo durante
el resto de su vida por ejemplo cuando
se desarrollaron nuestras manos
inicialmente nuestra mano era
un pedazo de tejido parecido a una
paleta pero fue gracias a la apoptosis
que poco a poco se definieron nuestros
dedos imaginen que esta es nuestra mano
y conforme se desarrolló cuando éramos
un embrión los tejidos sobrantes se
fueron re absorbiendo por otras células
que poco a poco formaron parte del resto
de nuestra mano así que esa fue nuestra
primera muerte celular por apoptosis y
después los restos fueron recogidos y
científicamente a estas pequeñas
burbujas se les conoce como ampollas tal
vez les parezca chistoso pero es una
palabra completamente científica y
podemos verlas en esta imagen de la
derecha esto es prácticamente lo mismo
que tenemos en el dibujo del lado
izquierdo tenemos una célula sana y
cuando ocurre la apoptosis del lado
derecho
podemos ver todas estas pequeñas
ampollas así que ahí podemos ver todos
los componentes de la célula empacadas y
listas para ser recicladas por otras
células
ahora quien me dicen de este renacuajo
tan raro bueno aquí sucede lo mismo que
decíamos de la mano pero en otro lugar
aquí la apoptosis influye en el
desarrollo de la metamorfosis de un
renacuajo a rana
este es un renacuajo que ya está muy
cerca de convertirse en una rana y tal
vez no lo sabían pero los renacuajos
tienen una cola muy larga y cuando se
convierten en ranas ya no tienen colas
porque la pierden mediante la apoptosis
que simplemente consiste en reabsorber
la cola y reutilizar esos componentes
celulares bueno no sé exactamente si
empieza a desaparecer desde la punta
pero de alguna forma desaparece y eso es
impresionante entonces la apoptosis no
es tan literal como las hojas que caen
de un árbol no es que agarremos un
renacuajo de la cola y se rompa más bien
es algo que ocurre gradualmente poco a
poco se va formando parte del tejido de
la nueva rana y a nivel celular podemos
imaginar que las células planteen
de las células vecinas ese sería el
parecido que podríamos encontrar con la
caída de las hojas pero no
necesariamente es una caída como la
vemos a nivel de todo un organismo más
bien son pérdidas de una célula
individual entonces hasta ahora hemos
visto algunos ejemplos de apoptosis en
seres en desarrollo pero al principio
les mencioné que la apoptosis también
está ocurriendo justo ahora en nuestro
cuerpo y tal vez me digan ya que te
refieres es para mantener el mismo
número de células en mi cuerpo esa es
una gran parte del papel que juega la
apoptosis sobre todo en el sistema
sanguíneo que continuamente está
produciendo nuevas células y si
producimos nuevas células pero nunca nos
deshacemos de otras terminaríamos con
muchas células y eso no sería muy bueno
para el cuerpo humano porque de hecho
eso es algo que ocurre cuando hay cáncer
las células se acumula así que la
apoptosis también es una forma de
mantener el equilibrio y bueno como
estamos tocando el tema
el cáncer un gran favor que nos hace
nuestras células es que si alguna sufre
un daño en su adn que las puedan
predisponer para volverse cancerosas
primero tratan de arreglarlo pero si no
pueden bajo circunstancias normales esas
células morirán mediante la apoptosis
así se aseguran de que no se transmita
ese daño y que otras se vuelvan
cancerosas y ese es un papel protector
muy importante que juega la apoptosis en
un ser humano adulto y en cualquier
humano durante toda su vida o si quieren
verlo de otra manera podríamos decir que
es como un gran botón rojo de
autodestrucción si unas células se da
cuenta de que está desarrollando
síntomas cancerosos
simplemente presiona el botón y activa
una cascada de enzimas que provocan la
apoptosis así que existen muchas formas
en las que las células están progresando
contra el cáncer para poder detenerlo y
muchas de ellas involucran mecanismos
internos podríamos imaginar que una
célula realiza su
y supervisión y dice oh no mi adn no se
ve muy bien y no puedo arreglarlo pero
también podríamos tener una célula que
es observada desde afuera por otra
célula por ejemplo podemos imaginar que
una célula del sistema inmunológico
puede llegar y pegar una proteína por
afuera de la célula potencialmente
cancerosa y eso desencadena la misma
función no sé exactamente como sea el
mecanismo de comunicación pero se sabe
que es una interacción entre dos células
en la que una le dice a la otra ok
sé que algo malo te pasa y es momento de
envolver así que la apoptosis puede
ocurrir de dos formas pero casi en todos
los casos es una parte normal y
saludable del ciclo de una célula y
todas las células morirán de esta forma
bueno a veces hay células que mueren por
necrosis así que no todas las células de
nuestro cuerpo mueren por apoptosis pero
también existen otras formas de reciclar
las células que no se consideran como
de la apoptosis por ejemplo como en el
caso de las células de la piel que
pueden pasar por un proceso parecido
pero que no se considera como apoptosis
aún cuando es una forma regulada de
muerte celular así que tampoco podemos
decir que todas las células morirán de
esta manera pero es una forma muy común
en que las células mueren y son
reemplazadas